you get manny's huh yeah what you get
manicures no i don't you don't you guys
know what have you ever had
you got good hands oh thanks man i i no
i definitely don't get manicures i got
eight pair right here though you see
that oh you got the all the eight nice
you guys do mushrooms yeah sometimes
i'll do mushrooms and that's that's how
i know i'm feeling it because i look at
my hands and i go oh [ __ ] dude how did
you do
that
is it like
like a weekend thing once a month
probably
okay
what are you doing
a little a little yeah
you said you do you do them how often i
haven't done them in years but oh what
are you saying do you do them i thought
yeah he was not like have you ever in
the history of your life yeah i used to
take them i just do them and i i when i
say i i do them and i keep meaning to do
them yeah i keep meaning to do them
because you want to go with the greatest
thing in the world it's it's an amazing
you've got to do them it's like people
you never know
it's the greatest thing you'll ever do a
little bit better it's better than all
the drugs yeah really i'm terrified of
that have you done all the drugs have
you done heroin i heard that oh no i
haven't yeah that would probably be
better i guess yeah
people risk their lives
people go i hate teeth now yeah exactly
like nobody's on intervention because
they're doing too many shows
no you know what already lang said the
minute he did heroin he shot heroin and
he went like this i think he snorted it
he snorted you know what he said he goes
he said he goes he goes i just went back
and i went
oh i'm in trouble
yeah
it's not that good
yeah and you spend your life chasing
that dress
it was just you can't get it you keep
chasing that first high have you done
acid no
you want to try asking you've really
only done grooms dude no well i've done
like all the well you guys are naming
some really hard stuff yeah i don't know
i don't know what heroin acid
car manual
you don't even know what it's like man
is what i'm saying the best thing in my
life if i had to choose if i had to
choose like you can never have sex again
but you get to do mushrooms as much as
you want or you get to do sex i'd
probably still choose sex
i don't want to lie to you guys
you got to do some mushrooms you got to
try it dude we got it
but why like you know like colors are
vibrant and [ __ ] uh
it's like uh
it's the only drug that you go like in
you know like other drugs you just want
a party you're like no i mean you forget
right sometimes i'll drink i don't even
remember what happened yeah yeah with
mushrooms you can just sit there like an
ape and just go like oh god and just
kind of be in your world about the world
drama yeah everything it's like
like i
very hesitant to say this i don't know
about my my age but when i was younger i
did mushrooms i i tell the story
actually you talk like you're 900 years
old i know i am an old man when i was a
boy when i was a boy in the 60s
you guys teased him about his age so
much he's really believing it now
you're old man
you know this this one time when i was a
kid back before blacks went to school
with us back in the days
but i mean we like when you get to a
certain age you can be in your 30s 40s
if somebody says dude it'll change your
life you're like for a second for a
little while but you know we go on but i
will say that i took a four hour shower
i did way too many mushrooms oh right
this and how many is 20 years oh yeah so
this wasn't a month i will say that it
was life-changing because
because what i did was i decided i came
out of it
and i remember this i was like i'm not
going to lie about anything yeah yeah
i'm not gonna lie anymore yeah i'm not
gonna lie to myself and i'm not gonna
lie to anybody about what i want to do
with my life and i remember i sat my
father down and i said because i said i
think i'm lying about high at the time
no it was oh this was two days later and
i said to him i said i think i'm trying
i remember this i've never talked about
this but i remember i said i go um
i have a problem he said what i said i'm
trying to be like you and i'm not
not like you man and i said and you're
my hero you know because i thought
that's what a man is right and yeah
that's when i decided to be an actor
really you know yeah and in fact now
while you're tripping on shrooms you
also decide to get invisalign
i didn't i did my teeth again want to
better himself
he's like in 20 years later i finally
got around yeah yeah there is something
right
it's insane i know
it's funny that he keeps wearing it
because i thought he was just going to
stop
noticing it yes we noticed it and
everybody knows it you're like the thing
is about streams guys
you know when i get my look at my dad
you know what i said to my father you
know what i said my dad i said dad i
said dad
you're my hero a piece of [ __ ] you're my
freaking hero
and i'm gonna stop lying to myself such
a vulnerable moment i'm gonna stop lying
my boy who does it all the time and he
says micro dosing yeah i know people
that micro dose every single day yeah
but they do it from the chocolate yeah
yeah but a lot of these people are doing
the chocolates and they do the micro
dose i just eat a hole it's like a whole
long it kind of looks like a turd it
tastes like a slime it's terrible the it
tastes gross why not make them taste
better though we just mash it up with a
mushroom or not mushroom we mash it up
with like a banana so like you can't
really taste me my buddy randy here's
the thing i'll tell you here's people
yeah people say why do it because it
makes you happier and you don't stress
out about any of the stuff you're
thinking about and you start thinking
about stuff for how long though yeah
hours hours three hours though so you
gotta commit also then the next day
oh here's a good another good reason
i've written some of my smartest
material stand up comedy wise while i'm
when i smoke weed i i come up with
terrible things they're not funny at all
i don't mix well with wheat yeah but and
that's why i don't smoke it but like
with mushrooms i've thought of tons of
funny stuff and we just laugh like it's
i think it changes your brain chemistry
like mike tyson talks about that he
worked with this doctor i think he did a
four day retreat yeah and uh he said
that the i i think that's what he was
saying
the peace of mind i got oh man it's the
best it's amazing what's happening they
they help
that you know the psychedelic frogs
you drop it on your tongue yeah yeah
i try that so you would do that i'm
surprised you haven't yeah i know right
yeah that's like the night but i'm not
like a big drug guy i like that sounds
like a terrible breakup it sounds like
yeah i
i personally i swear to god i i'm gonna
start doing it but like the thing that
scares me is it it doesn't make your
heart rate go up no no no you just like
but i will tell you this if uh i've said
this a thousand times but if you aren't
dealing with something
get ready you're gonna start to do you
know what i'm saying like because you'll
take much of that i know if i want oh
yeah yeah i've been putting that off
haven't i yeah
i haven't been dealing with that
and that's that's what no honestly
that's what's scary honestly like if
you're not living up to something yeah
yeah yeah it it can [ __ ] you up a little
bit in that it'll get you
it'll get you real honest yeah it'll be
like oh yeah it's time to call dad huh
for real like it really you are it makes
you go through your brain and you might
that's why it's better that's why it's
the best thing yeah well i might see a
part of yourself you don't like i know a
lot of people do and then you can change
major trauma and they're when they go to
uh you know whatever to rehab they're
doing ayahuasca treats yeah well
ayahuasca is just like mushrooms except
you puke a bunch and you have to have a
guide i don't trust anything that i have
to have a guide well yeah it's not
absolutely but you do it within a group
like that if there's i don't like that
exactly
and also listen to this my ex one of my
ex's uh shoes
incredible lady like one of the most
beautiful like spirits of a human yeah
and she goes i'm gonna go on this
retreat and i was like all right you
know do what you got to do whatever she
goes
and the the guide says you know you're
welcome to come back once you're
tripping you don't have to wear clothes
here we're not bound by clothes i like
this and i'm going right yeah this creep
just encouraged my drugstore girlfriend
to go like yeah i'll come back with my
teeth like just completely that's yeah
it's kind of weird
acceptable if your name is ted but you
change the name to you know
ashanti whatever you're in the [ __ ]
and you're in the amazon you're trying
to [ __ ]
john why would you offer that suggestion
unless you're a creep
yeah what does clothes have to do with
it let me taking advantage of people
that are all jumped up like hey you know
if you want we can have sex with each
other yeah she came back naked
yeah but you know they found that dude
and uh he was uh i think he was he
worked for the government
and he was i think he worked like in
some intelligence agencies well you know
the guy he decided to i know somebody
knows me he decided to go and do a
retreat and i guess he took a different
kind of thing i think he took like he
wanted to get into the whole and these
amazonian like yanumamu kind of guys
were like all right you want to try the
[ __ ] there you go and he [ __ ] went on
a little walkabout in the woods and got
lost
and they nope they found him about three
days later dehydrated starving and
bitten to shreds bible
but then
then they had to send in an actual
search team like an american search team
because they didn't trust the because
they needed it but he was eaten by
wolves
he was naked yeah the guy's naked amazon
that wouldn't happen to me you know no
no no no no you you you want to do it in
your own i'd be fine out there you would
no oh i was like that's just what you
have to think when you do drugs well
here's my here's trivia question would
you rather be lost in the congo or the
amazon b let's take a little break from
talking with that dime piece jeff died
he's distractingly hot very tight too
hot to handle that right now says six
four you know he's a six five he's six
five or yeah uh but tell you what's hot
is this saturday's ufc 272. talking
about kobe compton jorge mazdal the main
event ufc 272 this saturday we have a
calabasas fight campaign 7 p.m pacific
only on thick boy but when you watch it
whether you're listening to me you're
listening to rogan and the boys you can
make some money with draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the ufc and man they have a
knockout offer for the new customers bet
just one dollar on the main event and
get 100 in free bets no matter what
could be a first round knockout a draw
whatever it is no matter what it is no
matter what the outcome you get paid if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
yet you can still feel the thrill of ufc
272 with draftkings free to play pools
everyone can enter a free pool with ten
thousand buckaroos and prizes answer a
handful of questions like how long will
the fight last who will walk out the
winner follow along to track your
results download the draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code fire
throw down just one dollar on the ufc
272 main event and get 100 free best no
matter the outcome that code fighter
this saturday a draftking sports book
the official sporting betting partner of
the ufc 21 plus minimum asian location
requirements very jurisdiction
sheetdockings.com sportsbook for full
list of requirements and state specific
responsible gaming resources for
reprehented minimum five dollar deposit
gambling problem call one eight hundred
gambler in tennessee call and text the
tennessee red line tn redline
1-800-889-9789 in connecticut call
hope 888-789-7777 or text hope ny four
six seven three six nine i think when
you do drugs
here's my here's trivia question would
you rather be lost in the congo or the
amazon i don't know the difference
between either i know right right now
you run
still know nothing about it africa is a
huge continent so wait you take i'll
take congo you got you got you got
amazon you got the con so you got
central and middle of africa
or you got or you got middle of brazil
or brazil it'd be easy for me look at my
skin tone bro okay so you're going kind
of going but easier what are you doing
where
are you going jeff i don't know the
difference still what what am i dealing
with africa
there's some wild tribes out there you
know and amazon too yeah i'm going 100
percent amazon i'm going to have one
tell me
tell them tell them what's in the congo
well let's start what am i dealing with
let's start with let's start with we
don't know yeah let's start with the
fact that you gotta pick a region i've
seen blood diamond you got chimps you
got low land gorillas that's all
adorable you've also got what they i
apparently these hybrid chimps that
rogan was talking about those those the
lion killers those those chimps that
walk on two legs that they've seen but
forget all that you got left this is
real you got you got lions snakes
mosquitoes are things that are going to
really make you sick please stay away
from any body of water we know that yeah
why well because because that's what
that's all that's but no jim brought up
all of africa
yeah okay so tell me about the amazon
now yeah what do we got the most
dangerous animals nile crocodiles no
that's all of africa elephant yeah
leopards and spotted hyenas yeah and
every snake they don't like people black
mambas green mambas puff adders gaboon
vipers what's up
bring up a puff adder what's a puff adam
snake he's adorable what about that guy
is that a pokemon that was a puff
pattern yeah god enjoy yeah
now the gaboon viper's got a two inch
two inch bangs i think it's short and
thick yeah right all right so far i'm
leaning towards africa
no we want to go all out collecting
some monkeys i like it that'd be that
that'd be the gaboon viper i saw that
that's 2000 i saw that tarzan i think so
i wouldn't be too worried about the
animals i'd be worried about those
tribes in africa
he's got art on his arms and he's all
huge yeah
well you got the
hutu extremists who went into the congo
to run away from the authorities yeah
but i would just say i agree with you
guys
i came i came i like what you're like
y'all yeah i'm with you guys
hey what did you guys say about the
other tribe i agree man
i agree you [ __ ] that tribe i just saw
the tribe a minute ago i told him i
don't want to be with you
i want to know why wait so tell me about
the amazon then
no crocodiles that are going to kill you
there's the jaguars
there's also known
okay
what's the river what's the what's the
river that cuts through there the amazon
but you have the nile yeah yeah but
there's a major river that cuts through
the amazon is there amazing
amazon you're gonna have problems with
that you're gonna have problems but it's
not it's not so much anything
it's not it's not crocodiles and cayman
are going to leave they're not the salt
water or nile crocodiles that will eat
you and hunt you the way you're [ __ ]
fellas right which one has more bugs
that's what i want to know well now now
that's amazing
they both suck
both suck for animals and i think the
animals are thinking well let's take it
out let's say you get uh a bug yeah
protective i think
yeah i think the congo the you're gonna
get malaria no no no forget millennials
i wish you got more bugs amazon or congo
i go i take less bugs which everyone has
left
both are terrible yeah well it's it's
the jungle there's bugs everywhere it's
wet damn yeah well he's the one that
gave us this damn scenario yeah the
answer is neither bro it's the youngest
yeah i don't wanna do either by the way
you're gonna be rained on a lot you're
gonna be cold as [ __ ]
i got a question for you all right so
you seen that movie the gray no i
haven't it's liam neeson and there's all
these wolves
so i watched that movie and i was like
bro i could kill a wolf if it was my
life depended on her i could kill a wolf
i could like kill a one wolf yeah give
me one
he might get me and i'm gonna i'm gonna
put my thumb in there
they can get big really big and that's
why they attack and pack well timberwolf
gets up to about 150 pounds i've seen
the big ones yeah and so i'm popping off
of the mouth going i can kill this have
you ever have you ever worn a bite suit
and had just uh just
finished because i think he's gonna say
well here's the thing i'm talking [ __ ]
i'm going i can't [ __ ] up a wolf one
wolf come on dude my life on the [ __ ]
snap its neck i'll kill the [ __ ] right
i'm going crazy i'm talking all this
[ __ ] yeah it's one right i might come
out of it all ugly and [ __ ] and i got
one arm or whatever but i'll [ __ ]
kill the wolf i'll win and then the next
day my buddy his wife all the people at
the movie theater with me start sending
me all these messages on uh they took
photos from like reddit or whatever
these wolves get big yeah this wolf's
way bigger than bigger than this guy
like i mean big big wolves
do you think he could do it do you think
he could kill a wolf well he here's the
thing of that of that size glad you're
asking the question i think yeah yeah
yeah it's an important question now i'm
going to get hold of my neck now yeah
exactly it's all good it's all good now
listen here's the thing about um when a
dog bites i'm not going to talk about a
wolf yet because they crack elk bones
they crack elk bones okay but i'm not
going to talk about that i'm going to
talk about average male weight is 137
that is a big
mother trucking animal and that's
average by the way 178 largest yeah now
please understand that when a police dog
just a police dog right i'm going to
give you i'm going to malinois shepherd
they wouldn't mess with me i'm a white
guy
jeff that's so rich please those are the
trains
dogs go let it slide
he's a good guy
he's nice benefit
yeah he's probably got nothing
pays his taxes he doesn't have a weapon
in his pocket he doesn't even do drugs
he does like those white collar drugs
i have id yeah go ahead come on man um
when they bite yeah when when it grabs
your arm right there or anywhere on your
hand yeah you understand that everything
shuts down like you can't use it anymore
you know the train dogs yeah they bite
so hard that they shut they kill all the
nerve and yeah so now you can't use your
arms so your arms gum if it bites you
right here your arm goes numb if it
bites you in the leg yeah what about a
wolf now a wolf it bites a lot harder
than that so a wolf when he locks down
on the old arm if he gets he can bite it
off if he gets it yeah if he gets it
gets it big f what if you've got a
machete in here
those dogs are trained to go for arms
and legs well
the walls can actually train to get
right to your side also i got really
your arm it disengages you i got a thick
jacket on too it's got to get through
that you know what i'm saying yeah
i was like it's breaking my arm so
that's through a bite suit yeah throw a
bite soon you got to try those the good
point here your challenge just seems to
go ass first your life is making the
line yeah like i'm saying i've got to
live well you're going to you're humans
have started coming he's coming
if he grabs you by the tummy right if he
bites your tummy you're [ __ ] you're no
here's a better question you call my
stomach a tummy yeah it's not nice
but if it's you and me jeff like it's
just you and me i feel like we could
take out one large you know take you out
of it what are we doing with him
very simple
if you and i we can kill a wolf here's
why you're taking the bite sorry you
have to yeah someone has to or i take
the bite but in this case i'm getting
behind that wall he's not going i'm
going to put him in a rear naked choke
he's not going to go for you though he's
going to go for the biggest because
he'll have meat he's going to go for the
biggest guy yeah yeah is that what they
do so now he grew yeah he goes for him
starving brett brennan yeah these wolves
are like jail right now
yeah yeah beef jerky over there show me
what you're doing to keep them away show
me what you're gonna do what the wolf
yeah i'm gonna go feet first my shoe
okay you're gonna kick okay well no i'm
just gonna be up like this okay um so
hopefully he bites your shoe yes okay
chances are you're not doing this though
right we're keeping our hands here we're
keeping its elbows we're elbows here
right we're elbows and we're kicking
uh-huh okay you can't have him grab your
hand big trouble no it's game over but
he's gonna latch out i don't think it's
game over you guys keep giving this wolf
too much credit he's gonna latch on if
he latches on he's losing eyes he's i'm
[ __ ] he fights two fingers oh yeah
immediately immediately
and i'm squeezing and he's going and
then we bash his head it just once he
falls asleep unless he taps out i mean
but then you're bleeding and i'm like
yeah i'm bleeding i'm like let's get
these pants off you now you know i got
to tie you off yeah
wait take get these pants off you got to
take that's science
because i don't want him i don't want to
have pants on him i don't know where
he's injured i have to check his whole
body you got to do a full body check
dude what's going on
get on your stomach let me ask you what
does it does anyone in this room watch
1883
no no no it sounds old well
you watch 1883 no nothing it's
everything yeah
yeah i won't ruin it because it just
came out
throw it out it just came out last night
of course we haven't seen you no no no
the finale okay
throw it at us dude it takes a lot for
me to cry
you grow really dude
that finale last night you know some of
the darkest [ __ ] i've ever seen in my
life really oh man especially you have
kids what made you think of this just
now i'm just thinking just i was trying
to get transition out of this fake wolf
story okay
yeah yeah i like it um
what's in the real world right now it's
so it's it was
so dark and tim mcgraw is such a good
[ __ ] actor oh yeah
my girl was crying
i was like you know i was filling up but
they weren't coming have you ever had a
show do that to you before never never
never i cried yesterday and now that
movie coda
oh with the what's the code the deaf
people yeah me
what the heck is this yeah what what
coda is child of adult of deaf adults so
you're you're a child but she she's
speaking she wants to be a singer
she's a deaf lady that wants to sing all
deaf actors all deaf actors oh really oh
yeah this chick follows me on twitter or
whatever yeah she's cute
yeah
i've seen her i know a lot of deaths
i'm cool with the deaths bro i don't
know that's the they don't know that's
they got to do no they don't care
i'm in there's a deaf college in uh dc
oh no i took sign language in high
school because i thought it'd be easier
than spanish such a baby i was wrong
nightmare it's so hard also just ruined
charades right like it's over there's no
charades now
uh but yeah we went 1883 and then
american idol debuted last night
favorite show if you didn't know that
jeff american american isle debuts
dude american idol
dude so i went from crying on 1883 this
young black guy comes on and he goes i'm
going to sing the song
that uh because he had a nephew who was
one that passed away a month ago in an
accident because i'm seeing the song i
should see the singing to him to help
him sleep died of young age dude i can't
do i can't handle that dude i get i'll
start crying nuts do you cry stuff like
this i can't handle i uh i think it's
maybe just me getting older but like i
cried pretty easy
oh yeah yeah i don't know what happened
especially that
because i'm not like that guy you're
like
i'm easily touched you don't have kids
yet which you have kids what song do
they sing
i forget it wasn't original
they don't do originals right uh very
rarely they have originals okay but dude
you're like holy so have you ever seen
the movie song like a pixar movie yeah
i've seen soul so i saw seoul gym on a
plane uh-huh and i i didn't just cry i
wept
like the people next to me were like
like i it was the smartest most sweetest
best movie i've ever seen
you know what [ __ ] me up on the plane
i mean i know it's older but uh
the one with will smith
oh i robot no no
oh bad boys
he cried he's like when martin lawrence
and will smith went to separate ways no
man
that made me cry pursuit of happiness
especially
why did i oh my god
i was when they were sleeping in the
subway i was [ __ ] bawling yeah that's
it that one got me for sure but luckily
i had a window seat so i was
yeah
just
like
you 1883 check it out i'm telling you
man really if you like yellowstone
some people think it's better than
yellowstone same rider taylor sheridan
taylor sheridan he's a beast
he's a [ __ ] hannah 1883. do you
remember back then in 1883 it's like if
you got shot you got sick one guy gets
bit by a snake
that's it yeah you're [ __ ]
and then in 20 years i was like well
this guy thinks if a wolf bites my arm
it won't work anymore that's true
so in 1883 if the wolf just looked at me
i'd be dead again
you're missing a point jeff you mean a
jerk no no i just i don't know how you
know all this wolf stuff oh i do okay
because he does that he knew what it was
he knew what a [ __ ] puff adder was
wilderness or whatever it gets like 50
million views so he'll go find like the
you know what what whatever has the most
powerful bite and he got bit by a he's
amazing you know he got stung by like
some crazy hornet [ __ ] like that yeah so
yeah he looks young he yeah he's pretty
young i have tiger that's his girlfriend
jesus christ oh no that's kim kardashian
i have his uh
that's his girlfriend
snake boy's killing it
scroll down that's his girl that big
tortoise that's probably
[Laughter]
but i've tiger watched that just because
it educates him on animals and stuff but
we're playing basketball yesterday
lizards out there he wants to [ __ ]
put his hand oh yeah no you get bit i'm
like no dude what are you doing
what the [ __ ] that's not what we're
doing here wait that [ __ ] snapping
turtle scares me no the scare the scary
one too he has a straight up black widow
he's trying to prove that they're not
dangerous oh not all all over his body
what a terrible thing to try to do yeah
that's all he does
i would do that that's a problem oh
that's what yeah that's a tarantula i
think i saw the no but that was like
everyone's who's been bit by the
transfer that's not the worst there's
another one bullet ant nope there's one
worse than the other is it the
executioner yes
he got so much execution or wasp and
he's like sometimes i feel like he's
over exaggerating he's on the ground
he's like no seriously turn the gears
off and his whole arm's like turning
white that's it he got [ __ ] up bro
look at that [ __ ] thing isn't it
weird that you can get famous just for
this kind of stuff oh but this guy just
leaned into animals so hard yeah that
they've given it
back though i want to see it but it's
got to burn like a bit oh it looked so
painful you would you would do it i
would just because i'm so afraid of it
you would want to you would want to know
what that would be
i'd be down for you you guys would be
dead like don't dare me because i might
do it and then it'd be me i don't know
if would people be around would would i
get attention
right then i do that actually there's
some sort of here's my show idea here's
the show idea this is so dumb instead of
hot ones each we both get stung by a
[ __ ] executioner and then do that we
try to have an interview
you're going to have three guests i know
right or you might have you me and frank
gorilla yeah can you imagine you're not
no you're not no brian but you're not
they're no these celebrities are how
great would that be you're all stung
you're like all right tell me about your
[ __ ] book or whatever you got yeah
well i think people yeah
i think you would have i swear to god i
think you'd have a lot of [ __ ] sick
people look at the jackass thing people
would be like
they're not interviewing anybody yeah
but people love a challenge everybody's
mine i think men and women would like to
see it yeah love you terrible idea no
celebrity would do it
i think we put it on patreon and we sell
we should shut up absolutely
no celebrity's gonna do that there's no
way you can it's like a continuous show
you know how long that is three episodes
it's you me frank grillo and then some
and i'll do it guys he might be down
that's why he's sam tripley but i'm
talking about life
i don't know if i'm gonna do it maybe
but like a-listers like like hot ones
has like you know seth rogen and people
but you know the hot ones probably
absolutely not no no
i'm shocked that hot ones took off i
mean because imagine before hot ones was
a thing ghost pepper pitching that must
have been impossible
yeah he wasn't getting like crazy
celebrities from the jump right that's
because you know complex is like kind of
strange when i first heard that i
thought it was the dumbest thing i've
ever heard and then people every once in
a while i'll do it yeah like hey we got
a tarantula you get some of the biggest
for ellen
hey ellen we got a black widow [ __ ]
come get some yeah you know well no the
problem is you can't do black widow wait
you're saying the celebrities won't get
bit no not a chance but what if that
just the hostess bit
and then he has to interview that's the
move yeah yeah because now
this last time was terrible [ __ ] that
when you get [ __ ] sick doing that all
the time like like probably health-wise
your producers like hey we forgot to
tape we didn't have a car we didn't have
a car there we got to do that over here
it's actually a terrible idea because
it's a ghost you'd have to do it every
time [ __ ] that but also the insurance on
that one yeah that's insane you have to
go to the hospital all the time no that
you have us like like coyote piercing
has like a staff on standby because
there's certain yeah like uh with the
rattlesnake and stuff and certain ones
you know and like
well only a certain amount of people die
from it because they have an allergic
reaction i'm not allergic to it it's not
it's not a big deal but you know he
doesn't know to you it's [ __ ] bit
this guy i gotta get into this i think
when you have a contest if you made it a
constantly how long people could last i
actually laughed no yeah no one's we
mean laughs yeah how do you like that
people are gonna die
name says
but the pain is so bad that you end up
kind of being like i'm [ __ ] out you
know i think right now
how have they not made squid game an
actual game show a youtuber did he did
yeah that's a great idea yeah but that'd
be a fun show i mean you don't die
obviously but like you would just do the
same things they did in squid games it's
called oh wait i thought he just called
ninja warrior i thought he just
recreated the set no he did that oh no
one died but
that's crazy i think it'd be fun i'd
like to run it you know like doing that
when we hop from the glasses oh yeah
yeah i mean not i don't want to die
which one i would love to do you
struggle at most whether you think uh
let's refresh the tug of war let's be
honest i mean this sounds so rude but
when they were doing this red light
green light man they those koreans were
[ __ ] at red light green light they were
bad because i don't think they grew up
playing it like we did they all died at
red light green lights half of them died
even
all the other ones you go oh i get
people die i mean the glass falls you
you warm [ __ ] all that stuff but like
when you see red light green light kills
like 300 of them you're like
and that was the first game so easy yeah
i looked at my girl i gotta dominate
things
i wouldn't be scared this is easy just
don't move yeah like hopefully all the
games now it moves and then we don't
move yeah it's so easy so [ __ ] scary
some people you know hey little shake
they they won a bunch of awards at the
sag awards last night yeah they did yeah
they won a bunch oh there was a war show
last night
which is what you know i was telling you
about this on the shop show it was weird
to watch the actors were like you know
what we do is so important and that's
this channel it's you train in war
you're like [ __ ] dude by the way
really dark yeah well that's what i was
what is something going on in ukraine
but it puts into perspective what's
going on like you know like the chairman
of the psychiatry board do you see this
in colombia got suspended indefinitely
because there was a there's a there's a
sudanese model
and she calls herself the queen of dark
and all he said was somebody said
somebody posted this this tweet was like
this is not a piece of granite or art
this is a human being she's beautiful
and all that and then he said the
psychiatrist goes ah she's gorgeous she
goes whether a work of art or a freak of
nature she is a beautiful side to behold
oh wow boom
and that did it oh no not like that no i
had to wait freaking you're racist
you're you're you're you're fetishizing
you're erraticizing her body that's
gorgeous i mean a massive a massive a
massive outcry ready and then he like a
dummy goes apologize i i my apologies to
the black community and women are not
enough enough
i i i have caused so much hurt and i'm
beginning to understand the personal
work i have to undertake oh well he made
this guy trying to keep his job yeah
yeah trying to get his job of course
they were like an apology all of them
were like apology it's not enough oh
it's great that you can just go on
living and learning so he's done right
he's done
all it was was a clumsy he made a clumsy
compliment is it clumsy though right he
said it's just his perspective where he
should be canceled for him no but they
canceled him but columbus being racist
he's
and sexist and eroticizing and
fetishizing a black people the words
were this woman kind of woman and the
model herself she she's from sudan and
she goes yeah that's straight up racism
cool
hold on would you rather be in the sudan
because they can teach you something
about not only racism but also ethnic
cleansing genocide i mean they can t
they can they can teach you something
like russia and ukraine are dealing with
real problems real problems so is the
sudan so you we as americans
this uh we come up with
the hurt
there's like a movement on twitter where
people like man if they're trying to
draft our young males i'm not going blah
blah and then like i saw that oh yeah i
posted this then like a real army
sergeant was like hey don't worry if
china tries to invade this we're not we
don't need your help you think most you
males are out of shape couldn't pass the
exam most you're too into social media
and into drugs and just too weak to help
us out trust me we're not going to
recruit well and here's the other thing
i'll do no
i got guns i'll do pretty good
yeah well that's what we all say right
so i'm second guy own guns in case the
government comes at me not the governor
no it's not the guy i don't know i must
try to raid the capital i know yeah i'm
saying they're supposed to be on my team
i'm saying i'm saying the idea is that i
mean i need it yeah but but there are a
lot of guys they're actually guys from
america and everywhere else that are
going into ukraine to fight the russians
okay these are regular dudes yeah uh on
the on the ukrainian side
it's great it's great there are a lot of
guys if you're a male if you're a male
from 16 to 40 you can't leave the
country you have to go pick up a gun and
fight for your country got it now here's
the really gangster here's another good
fight they had a they had a general on
who said he said
okay you guys everybody's got their guns
and they're all ready and the and the
president is saying give us arms the
russians the russians uh in kiev these
and odessa and these other cities
they've surrounded those cities and they
surround those cities with something
called artillery now the artillery they
have can take an area the size of
central park and demolish it that fast
just literally level it annihilate
everything and everybody in it okay
so your guns all your guns they have no
the ukraine has no air support this guy
was like the ukraine doesn't have air
support it doesn't have like a uh air
force well they do but they don't have
the equivalent to russia yeah yeah
so so
they are surrounded with this artillery
so all your guns all your stuff you're
all ready and stuff means literally [ __ ]
all because those guys though that
military machinery artillery and the
kind of weaponry they have can level
all the buildings but they're not doing
it like you want to put up a fight i
don't think we should shame those people
i think i'm shaming them i'm not sure
but also
saying there are a lot of americans
going in there
there are people going in there with the
idea that they're going to fight the
russians
putin very there's a putin's going to do
whatever he wants to correct those guns
sound racist you know
why does everything's right they would
kill uh
everyone even
black models and everything i'm not
saying there are black models i don't
think the black models are gonna get
killed nuclear can't do that
those guns
sound generous
whatever and unfortunately i don't
because because i think what putin has
overlooked is how strong ukrainians are
so when they're going in there they're
they thought he he thought he was gonna
be able to take it over in about a few
days and that's not happening it could
then it's not happening he could though
maybe he's not though uh no he's not
because of public international pressure
i don't think he wants to level the city
it would get it's already costing yeah
it's not gonna it's i'm saying if he
wanted militarily but what he's doing
now the war he's doing now on the ground
ukrainians are putting up one hell of a
fight with a fraction of the people well
first of all the other thing is that
there are a lot of ukrainians who i
think especially in eastern ukraine who
speak russian and identify as russian
it's a very weird it's a weird conflict
here man because a lot of the ukrainians
there are there are a lot of ukrainians
who speak russian who identify as russia
have you have you heard about the one
guy uh jeff is texan but have you heard
about i'm not saying i'm looking up the
name vladimir doesn't sound very russian
[Applause]
his name is vladimir putin
have you heard this one guy he became a
star overnight he's uh uh a jet pilot
for ukraine
the ghost of kids i think that might be
a that might not be are you that guy
yeah they may think it might not be real
now because he was he was back tomorrow
they got him on video he came back the
next day sure
you don't think so brian i have
skeptical hippo eyes about why
what is that hippo
super pro russia yeah russia at all i
haven't picked a side yet i gotta hear
it all out russia i i get i get very
worried because people are talking
romantically about about the ukrainian
ukrainians winning this war because no
no they're not going to win you're
you're mistaken yeah the the the they're
saying they're putting up they're
putting up a fight i'm very against this
invasion let me be very clear i think
it's great for it
i think it's outrageous but there are a
couple things do you also root for the
empire in star wars
she's always like darth vader i think
he's fat i'm very against this invasion
and i think it's crazy i just don't
think that i think that
if the russians decided to actually go
to war here and actually take that
country over they could do it
immediately so why are they doing it
this way because they go the other way
then we will get involved no no yeah and
and the main one these problems yeah but
do you know why they came in do you know
what the main crux no it doesn't
said from day one he was like if if the
country on my border which used to
belong to the soviet union if you guys
joined the north atlantic treaty
organization
if georgia joins the trade north
atlantic treaty organization which is a
treaty it was it was started after world
war ii
which was the european country said
we're part of nato and and the united
states is going to back us up meaning if
if the soviets invade one country we all
come we all come it's it's a treaty
organization
now on his border
with a large population that speaks
russian
when the ukraine said we're going to be
a member of nato and the united states
refused to say well where the united
states and europe said we're not going
to tell them not to be part of nato we
can't
to the soviets i mean to putin that is
essentially saying
now i have an enemy who is allied with
the west militarily
on my border with a huge segment of the
population that speaks russian brian can
you describe it longer
[Laughter]
about two minutes in i'm going
they all got together what the hell is a
treaty they all said all right we agree
i started thinking about book of boba
fett is that when they all kind of met
everybody can you i missed them can you
restart from the top
star wars confusion you have the
alliance right yeah you know what's
crazy though you got the klitschko
brothers with ak-47s you're sick you got
lomachenko who flew out there wow are we
safe that's what i want to know are we
good
we're good i think what's going to
happen is they're going to negotiate i
think putin doesn't want this you're
creating someone yeah there's a lot you
got to make a stance oh there's some
guys
and you can't kill the top guy right
nobody wins nobody wins here
i think what's gonna happen is [ __ ]
uh they're gonna they're talking uh i
just it makes no sense yeah like there's
no upside like south korea and north
korea have been at war
forever yeah and nothing ever happens
they just they meet and they go okay no
more noise games don't make sound it's
annoying everyone will not do that and
then then they're like they'll get like
one guy 10 years later start blasting
the things again and then they'll say
let's have another meeting it doesn't
really feel like a war you're going to
have i think i think the ukraine is
going to have to say we will not have
any u.s bases we won't have any european
military base it's going to be a whole
thing okay he also bombed what did he
bomb a bunch of military installations
anyways like you guys want to have an
air force sorry you know you took that
yeah it's it's a gamesmanship yeah yeah
this isn't hopefully it ends soon though
it's backed up it's [ __ ] up and it's
not good yeah
our friend uh [ __ ] from tehran
tactical who she's ukrainian and she's
got family there she's already lost some
friends there she's got her [ __ ]
family there i'm surprised that the war
is still happening because i was driving
through sherman oaks and there was a
bunch of people out there with signs
some surprise that they're still doing
it
with all these got the protesters
there's gonna be like there must have
been hundreds of people yeah and they're
still doing it yeah they're still doing
that war even though all my neighbors
are out there
making a difference
yeah that that would end it
yeah but it didn't oh wait wait hold on
the greatest though is steven seagal
it's probably going to be that's fake
that's fake it's fake yeah
who who's not embedded in this fight
i just read it this morning though again
would you rate it on uh twitter can you
yeah sam tripoli and daddy bravo dude i
saw an instagram thing just like a few
days ago it was like a soldier had died
and this uh they brought in his dog like
and the dogs like was been with him
through military and stuff and the dog's
all like rushing just to get to the
coffin and it puts its paws on the
coffin everyone in the funeral is like
again the dog lays by the cough and it's
like so sweet and i was like i wanna
watch like the full youtube video of
this this is really beautiful this dog
like loves this man it's from a goddamn
movie
they just took that scene and put like
beautiful music over
how loyal dogs are to their own and it's
like i fell for the same thing yeah
yeah because he was he was but also but
also this other thing like people in
ukraine like hey hey [ __ ] it's three
degrees in ukraine right now that
picture's from a summer of course
but also figured out everybody right you
thought that was real brian i knew i
thought roger was citizen what did you
think was what did what does rogan and
callum think was real i don't know he
thought steven seugal actually was
actually joined for russia
he's a russian because he's a russian
citizen so
they thought that he was actually
fighting for russia yeah even though the
picture is him from a movie right it's a
movie what is the middle
when did seagal get so fat
he just let himself go yeah he used to
be like a good looking you know strong
guy yeah i literally thought everybody
thought that was fake
like i didn't say there you go
by rogan others is fake the image jews
is actually from a 2017 film called
cartels which features the veteran
action movie star in a minor role as a
member of elite special op squad yeah
i bought it [ __ ] hook line and sinker
that's insane
i thought rogan's doing it just as a
joke i can just see segal doing it
though
what
he's an actor he's a russian citizen i
can just i know he's a russian citizen
but like i can't i can see him yeah i
mean i don't think he would go that far
this guy's a [ __ ] he's movies i mean
he does it wasn't it cop or something he
shows up at black house and teaches
people shaq was a cop chad loves cops
yeah he showed up once for promotion
right he's not a coach there no i know
he's not a coach there but he still acts
like one and talks about teaching very
rarely he doesn't go to black house and
train people well he came there for the
camera who do you think would win in a
fight stephen
or brendan chubb would you say you think
he could take segal oh my god you
kidding me yeah you think he could take
him come on whatever he wants
we should set that up kyle's never been
in a ring he's never what i thought he's
like a fight guys oh didn't he fight all
those people blindfolded or something
like that let me see
that
he's never been in that damn that's the
thing that got me he's never
he's never been in a ring really her
cage no
i mean i thought he was like throwing
dudes blindfolded and [ __ ] yeah
apparently cigal's naming in russia
right now
yeah i mean
that's too bad yeah yeah yeah
he says he's some he's way bulkier and
less fit than the man i know he knows
the soldier that's preferred to me
doesn't need to have a resemblance to
the actor in his younger years but upon
cleverness so this is our parents so is
there there is a picture of him that
looks like this guy looks like him
there's a guy with black hair that they
you know
i think people want steven segal to be
the guy that does this but rogan took it
down didn't he or something he replaced
it yeah he said that then he messaged uh
then he put that message with what i
just highlighted there that he was
banned from flying to the or to
the ukraine because he has ties to the
kremlin criminal yeah
but that's the only truth i guess that's
the truth i haven't even fact checked
that either but
yeah what's the crime you know sean
russian uh government
okay i don't know i don't know the
kremlin sean pence and uh
uh ukraine uh he's in ukraine because
he's trying to film a documentary of
course he is
that guy it's like dude just
insufferable i mean did you guys see
louie performing during the raid like he
had shown he cancelled it i thought he
said he go oh
bring that up too we have no idea what
is real anymore is it kind of crazy
though
i mean look at it though like literally
what just happened it's so common steven
fighter no you brought up a thing and he
goes that was fake yeah and rogan got
duped too then you go did you see louis
lego no that was fake and then you go
hey wasn't he blindfold fighting people
you know that was for everything we've
nothing we don't even know what
yeah no those got canceled why did it
start has cancelled the comic
why is that how they're describing them
see that says
not performing in ukraine and russia
this is here
oh it's by fan
um so they haven't confirmed anything
yet was he supposed to or something yeah
he was on on tour in russia in uh
ukraine
i didn't even know they did shows there
he's been doing shows like olive and he
was all over yeah did he perform for the
kremlins or whatever
i still don't know they are uh it's the
kremlin the kremlin i don't know what
that is it's the sort of the uh would
you guys do you guys go to college or
something how do you guys
him on stage no no no video but i saw
like i
i saw a picture of you i guess yeah so
he is performing he's not okay no no but
clearly not though right we know that
jesus said he's in the middle of a war
just said he didn't know that's it
but the actual headlines are he came i
find it's important to laugh even in a
time of war you know because that's
february 24th what's today 28th
get louie out there you know these
people need some yeah try to go to a
newer post jen i saw that all my times
had it but i don't have a subscription
that's three days low three days ago
um i'm sure if you go down i'm sure
everything starts so now i would imagine
people who hate louie will be happy to
hear
i'd imagine he's not doing it
um
[Music]
jeez this is so negative yeah yeah of
course
controversial community everything is
it's february 26th we see you guys
perform ukraine but has canceled the
shows there you go guys yeah you can't
do stand-up during a war what imagine
yeah yeah
how do you feel like comments your agent
going to go go ahead hey man i know it's
not that big hey flights are real cheap
right now
you know what flights are cheap hotels
definitely
also dude these fans can't wait to get a
laugh
can you fly to ukraine right now could
you just fly try to book me a flight to
ukraine i'll give you my
fight you don't see what happens we are
[ __ ] insane you can't
you can't fly out of russia so the
problem is is there's ufc fighters who
are supposed to fight soon and they
can't get out of russia oh wow oh [ __ ]
and then also the national basketball
team can't fly out of russia why don't
they just drive
not a bad idea drive and take a boat how
about you want it man hey you gotta get
how far away is that no it's it's on
it's own no-fly zone
i know i'm just saying if we could
actually try to buy tickets here yeah
you can't fly into warren torn countries
i want to go to ukraine but sean penn
probably took a private job i would
imagine oh yeah he's got another thing
dude imagine being sean penny like
there's a war everybody get your cameras
i've got a film
no you go you go to a country that
borders it and then you drive in that's
how they're doing it the borders are
closed though do you ever see that
documentary where sean penn like
basically dated a girl just to get um
el chapo el chapo he dude he's going to
get el chapo [ __ ] caught yeah and
they almost got that woman murdered
like yeah he like risked all these
people's relationships
reporter yeah he was a terrible guy he's
not like a very honorable guy he goes i
gotta get the film you gotta get the
[ __ ] he went he did this with a rock but
then he wouldn't but then like our
governor was like hey dude tell us in
mexico where you went well and he was
like i can't do that yeah because he
wanted to be the guy but then it was a
tax or el chapo cena take some and
that's how we tracked him down yeah got
him they were watching he's lucky to be
alive yeah sean penn yeah you're gonna
mess with el chapo are you insane
well i think el chapo wanted to be
famous too anybody wants to be no sean
penn was there because he uh make a
movie he wanted to do the life story
yeah
okay sean penn
yeah i mean i mean great actor
phenomenal actor and i guess they got he
got
it was the girl he was it was the
soap star that chapo his
it's
mistress
huh well it wasn't really his mistress
he he he liked her but she they didn't
hook up over another that's what she
said i promise they hooked up how do you
know he's out there
hanging out with her i think el chapo
i don't know when you're when you're
when you run mexico
i just believe all women you know and
she said they didn't
jeff i [ __ ]
she said they didn't have sex she said
she did say that jeff you've got a
you've got a choir boy smile
yeah that's the devil's a real handsome
fellow
red horns going around you're sucking me
in you sucking me right in bro
i'm jealous of your you know you're
taller than brendan i know you're
talking yeah that's all i have what are
you six six six four no
i told you brandon you feel like you're
like what are you saying huh you're not
six five someone told me that the other
day i guess i'll start saying six five
yeah you just say it [ __ ] do you ever
feel like you don't
yeah but you don't use your size you
don't know you never you
shove around you never did it you don't
bully anybody no way man why would i do
that i don't know i feel like because
he's from seattle they weren't able to
be my friends those are big shovers
never shovel never take a guy who's my
words to bully people is that what it is
yeah it's fun smart guy
all right jim what do you got for us
brother
you gotta you gotta pay attention to the
mattress you're sleeping oh it's
everything spend too much time
in bed bro
okay so if you're gonna sleep in your
mattress
you're spending a third of your life at
least if you're smart in bed but you
just don't want a math just built for
everybody if you got a thick body skinny
body helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete matches
your body type and whatever however you
want to sleep with the perfect mattress
just for your thick balm amazing
mattress is great for spinal alignment
prevent morning aches and pains even
even has uh it's good for plus size
sleepers you're a bit of a plus size
plus size dude yeah you are um listen
man i took the quiz i have it at my crib
i sleep on every night my beds and my
guest rooms are helix sleep mattresses i
can't get rid of my in-laws my family my
mom's coming this weekend they say it's
because they love me really it's just
because they love my mattress i love the
magic sleep mattress take the quiz so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress that's
your match to the mattress comes right
to your doorship for free you know helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazines that's insane dude just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minutes
sleep quiz the match you with your very
own mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty but also you can try it out for
100 nights risk free if you don't love
it they'll even pick it up but you're
gonna love it don't worry about it man
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners and viewers at helix
sleep.com fighter wow 200. listen b car
shopping can be real tricky man it's
confusing it's stressful finding the
right car can we trick your dudes what
do we do dude there's a shortage so
you're like what do i do yeah i tell you
what you do you go to admins they go the
extra mile to make car buying easier by
providing shoppers with honest car
reviews video test drives online
shopping tools all right i'm not i'm not
a car guy so i need somebody to do the
work for me so you're saying edmunds is
the car yeah man listen they have over
50 years of trusted car shopping advice
and price guidance all in one freaking
place all right edmunds unbiased
research reviews they have experts to
help you out making the right decision
man car shopping can be overwhelming
edmonds is here to help visit admins.com
click on edmonds best car rankings to
research and compare vehicles that's
edmunds.com
edmonds we drive it like it is
you can rest those big hands on
someone's head like pick them up just
talk to them actually brian your video
first right
what's this this is a ukrainian football
who gets subbed in in europe watch the
reactions no spoilers
[Music]
[Applause]
so
pretty cool
yeah shooting milk and honey everywhere
this is milk and honey
so we have an imagine 2.0 where
last week the actress annalynne mccord
had recorded a video of herself reciting
a poem that she wrote about putin's mom
yeah about how she wishes she was
putin's mom because he'd be so loved
that he wouldn't
cause all this yeah
i had a feeling it'd be stupid but i did
think she was uh yeah that's right my
girlfriend told me if she could talk to
saddam hussein
no she goes she goes i could get too
much what we broke up will she hide i go
wow this is yours yeah she goes she goes
i would reach him here i would talk to
him oh my god these people who thinks
like you know
how do these people get i'm gonna let
you speak first of all no he would yeah
he's listening to a female i mean do you
know anything about him yeah if you were
putin's mom he'd go quit with the stupid
poetry you dumb [ __ ]
i have to go rule some [ __ ] and be
number one of the country i haven't seen
the video
a smoke show she's from niptuck
90210's uh reboot in the 2000s oh okay
poem
she literally did a [ __ ] poem
yeah it's hilarious what is she in sixth
grade oh she's getting eaten alive for
this of course you know who else is so
is your boy chin john cena
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved
oh i can't watch it joyous isn't it
great never would the stories plight the
world unfurled before our eyes a pure
demise of nation sitting pieces how many
takes do you think she did before this i
was your mother she's a professional
maybe two
more than that okay
i think she's reading off of a laptop
oh she didn't even memorize the poem i
don't think so
steal it
i don't know she might that's why i
think she's had a bunch of takes yeah
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you listen also professional is a
very loose term cat
i mean she's been working in the
industry for a while you now decide how
can you have this much sympathy for
putin
and then cancel anyone at the drop of a
hat oh it's for doing anything remotely
like like unintentionally
you don't want to shame putin where's
all this sympathy for deleo or like
anybody who did like the louis right
every had like canceled comedian
because he pulled his wiener out but
then putin putin if i was your mom putin
i know right
i would hold you to my nipple and the
world would be better you [ __ ]
self-righteous [ __ ] she's getting eaten
alive for that
john cena wanted to promote his his uh
oh yeah his new show peacekeeper where
he's uh because he's a peacekeeper
he was like if only and whatever his
character's name is he's like only if
jack could get to ukraine right now and
then posted a link to a story oh god the
cancer culture is like excuse me
dude he was just like oh i [ __ ] up
hey we're dumb as [ __ ]
not
he's funny you like him i don't i'm not
crazy about it i don't like superhero
stuff yeah i like john cena though i
mean i think you know it's
the taiwan thing you know yeah who knows
what i mean but this is the second time
he's really [ __ ] up just stay out of
it too i don't know it's like just yeah
all right he might have been looking
around that lady wrote
yeah like he's a smart guy yeah not a
good luck he's not stupid yeah but then
he's also thinking about how to promote
[ __ ] you know but in what world was he
saying as i was like oh there's a war
russia ukraine oh if they had the
peacemaker that's hilarious yeah
he had to make it about him yeah yeah
you know what that was a good point if i
was hitler's dad
i think that i don't think all that
stuff would have happened yeah
i'd have played catch with him
yeah but i held his little hand this
poor lady has no idea what backlash
she's getting i bet she actually ended
up doubling down she did a follow-up
interview with buzzfeed a few days after
saying that she went through a lot of
early uh like on-set trauma with her
parents and that she could understand
trump
people continue to use that as an excuse
as to why they do dumb [ __ ] yeah you
know what i mean like hey everybody's
been through [ __ ] something as a kid
it doesn't mean you can [ __ ] act like
a jackass yeah you know sorry enemy get
mad well maybe no but you're right i
mean but here's the thing i just don't
understand that you can have
you can express such it is really nice
what she's saying she believes that she
would be so sweet that putin would be
this great guy or whatever but like then
you got to be consistent on that if
you've got to keep that same sympathetic
you're going to die who's the murderer
yeah bonafide murder yeah then you must
be the best person in the world you
might because people cut you off in
traffic oh no big deal if i was his mom
who knows
if she was here no i'd probably be the
same way
pretty committed to this yeah
i'm with you
yeah i'll deal with the [ __ ] yeah
she'd probably be into me because i'm
[ __ ] putting her in her face no
sometimes you gotta sometimes you gotta
confront a [ __ ] it's a little
bit it's a little bit like the other
side who take responsibility that video
oh that [ __ ] remember that video
actors like i feel like that's the worst
thing hollywood's ever done the when the
george floyd stuff happened and i take
accountability
almost said holler back
oh god it was he was the worst oh my god
that's so awful how many times you use
the n-word
it's so obvious i'm taking
responsibility for all these texts
that'd be great if they just started
showing what they've done yeah it would
have been better if they were in the
middle of saying that somebody flew into
frame and just [ __ ]
threw them in a headlock and just took
them out just held them down
just every one of them
black guy yeah i just like that reebok
commercial no the guy with the huge dick
they take all the pictures he takes one
they slap
a guy like that just naked and just
comes running in and just [ __ ] i got
to be based
i don't know for the shock for the gram
what else
i can't believe that poem i'm more
outraged about that poem than the war
so we talked about war for a long time
and i was just i was okay and then
and then the poem just something about
it that you are very frustrated the poem
was triggered
because you know what it is she's in a
nice like million dollar apartment oh my
god
i think it's got a statue of buddha back
there because i do yoga rings dishonest
yeah all this all desperation moral
exhibition and and all this [ __ ]
virtue signaling it they know in their
hearts they're not making a difference
when it comes to equality it's not
making she's doing it to
for the grant right like was she even a
mom um who cares
maybe but yeah she had any funny she
wasn't a mom yeah she goes if i was your
mom you don't even know what it's like
to be a mama that's right she's a mom
that's a really good question if i was
just i don't think she's a
mother over the same age
yeah i'm sure she's a nice person and
we're kind of you know she's [ __ ]
gorgeous she's super pretty i'm not
saying she's not a nice person i'm
saying the poem and the the idea of that
poem oh god i see her man
oh no
i mean she'll have no kids
that's her man i see him every single
morning which one
uh go back yeah
oh this guy he's from uh uh blade two oh
great you're gonna have to apologize for
me after this oh yeah like hey it was
her man they were dating for a while but
i think they broke up yeah i see him
every morning yeah
i've seen her making a strong face
that's a strong face
they both got strong faces when you
think about it all right what else you
got yeah
here we go if i was your mom so a tick
tocker went online and recorded his
tinder matches before and after
photoshopping himself with a fake
lottery winning photo
before he had no
what is it like a swipe right nobody
wanted to date him and then right after
he photoshopped this like multi-million
dollar lottery winning as his avatar he
got a bunch of matches this is the video
whatever the [ __ ] key couldn't get
imagined
[Laughter]
just bunch of people that is [ __ ]
hilarious yeah
the least surprising news i've ever
heard
yeah gold diggers yeah that crazy that
women like guys with money yeah oh i
heard so my buddy is scopa the bartender
yeah i was with a friend of mine and uh
on on the internet about for the longest
time said i was worth 200 000 that's it
this is like and i've been you know and
i'm older and this is and uh these women
thought i was cute they were at the bar
and these two girls were like they saw
me and my friend they're like he's cute
the bartender goes they looked up your i
go yay he's actually backwards they
looked at me where i said 200 grand they
got they left they were like ugh [ __ ]
that guy
really damn
it'd be like that did you a favor it's
almost a favor that shows you up to him
hey everybody
let's look up chappelle lacy's net worth
on oh hell no what if this happened
no but what if that happened
see what they would see if they would
walk away at
yeah let's get let's get the you know
get the teacher please don't leave after
our sex tape was the air dropped 100 no
no a teacher in
uh i couldn't find a photo of her what
but this future in transformation ohio
had her she's claiming that she thinks
her phone got hacked because four videos
from her phone were airdropped to all
the students in that school about a
hundred people got it and she works at
an all boys private school keep that in
mind three of the four videos were
normal and then one video was of her and
her boyfriend having sex oh we can find
it for sure it didn't say your name
though right to be airdropped though
it's got to be like in the senate
ohio teacher sex tape it's going to pop
in current events this ought to be great
i bet you she's a bona fide smoke show
if you're filming yourself having sex
you're probably pretty hot yeah trolls
really don't like warlocks it's not like
like two big people
supposed to record this yeah
do they because i just picked it up i
mean i started asking my
friends lot of the teachers are super
hot you feel bad for her
look at that one right there the third
down that's probably ohio
[Laughter]
it's like a college dorm or something go
buckeyes oh good tough
yeah
but did you see your big sean he's a
small guy his name is big sean oh i know
you're talking about i can't believe i
sent a curve back but big sean
on his instagram story leaked a dick pic
and he was like wait that's not mine
dude
this dude has a
dick on him that's why he
no it's his for sure and he's like no
that's my friend because this [ __ ] was
leaked before yeah well you have your
friends dude though this is what he did
right yeah but this is what he did he
took a nintendo switch and put it next
to his dick and my son has an intense
switch so i get the ruler out
dude it's it's over nine inches okay
it's nine inches long all right so his
dick's bigger than the nintendo switch
dick and it's harder it's just a soft
that see that's
that's it right there what he didn't
have
why would he put it next to a nintendo
switch so you know so you know
but who's he trying to hook up with
gamers
[Laughter]
i don't know because he had to go find
his kids nintendo switch to find out how
big a man's penis was hey sally brought
a nintendo
and i told my girl hey where's our ruler
at roulette give me the tape measure i'm
like that's quite a scavenger hunt you
know you gotta that's impressive you
have to do some uh research and i would
just write oops
not do anybody want to play
why wait yeah so we didn't answer that
it was is it was hard right
uh not like rock acid not flaccid
nintendo switch chubbed chubbed up you
tall kid you're working with a piece are
you doing oh yeah yeah i'm doing good
all right good good yeah yeah so it's
not like oh you're so tall but it's
regular i like i'm doing it i'm doing it
fast too right all right yeah you're
right i know what i got what it don't
all right there's no big shot up in here
though not a big shot long and thick
that's a yeah that's a whole difference
big sean that's what i call it that's
why he's called that yeah yeah he is
because this isn't about my height it's
like five seven it's about my switch
dick python he wins
not over
the nintendo switch yeah he's playing
with my son old switch dick yep feeling
good
there is a video of rick ross going
around where he is complaining about
getting quoted ten thousand dollars to
cut down the trees in his house so he
decided to
go to home depot grab a saw and cut it
down himself what ten thousand he done
got ten grand
i mean it's the it's the uprooting of
this morning and i just got my estimate
i got like tea trees
i want to cut down
they say them big trees them big oak
trees rose i said i don't care
i want them cut down
i'm [ __ ] up just a vibe right there
[ __ ] told me a thousand dollars a treat
for ten trees that's ten thousand okay i
just told my homie you go to home depot
and you go get me the biggest
[ __ ] saw there is with a big
chain and you crank that [ __ ]
i'm gonna cut the trees down you heard
me
what's he so mad at you trees i'm not
cutting down oak trees don't do that
though why does he forgot who the [ __ ] i
am geez is he dressed like this don't i
cut down my own [ __ ] trees this
new joe exotic looks less
[ __ ] he's so mad at trees for my
animals
what animals
y'all ready to go cut these trees down
dude i mean yeah i guess i'm ready oh
that's super dangerous how much no yeah
but do you see the stump that's why you
need them to remove it that stump is
never going to leak also how much was
that chainsaw 10 grams no [ __ ] that's
also
right it's very dangerous oh it's super
you know how to cut a tree down
and i don't think he's the most elusive
guy on the planet and this looks like
it's taking forever yeah also also
that's those are cool trees man that's
an old tree hey rick ross chill though
gotta be at least a hundred you gotta be
careful when you cut it because you fall
the other way yeah man chainsaws are
cheap i was way wrong how much
100 bucks 200 bucks
i thought they were respecting that
oh he [ __ ] did it
oh that's a big tree
[Music]
yeah i mean i hold things up
i mean i guess congrats man
people were also leaving commenting that
it was actually a really good estimate
considering that they chop down the tree
they will cut it up into pieces and then
remove it from the site
yeah so odds are he cutting so he won a
tree
and then had to have them come cut the
rest and then carry it out also i
thought it was a big part of like his
you know like rap and stuff to like be
like ball i got money yeah maybe 10
grand you should have said it would be
like 200 grand i said [ __ ] that yeah
yeah and they tried charging me a
millionaire yeah
yeah yourself 10 million i ain't having
it right that makes sense he's like man
they're charging 200 a tree yeah this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] a thousand dollars
total he's filming it in his palace
uh this is [ __ ] to save 10 grand you
go to home depot he sent a guy to home
depot
he didn't even go himself falling so
hard you got an assistant to get you a
chainsaw but you can't afford the tree
where is that
i am not usually also why did that tree
have to go it wasn't for some reason
that didn't seem like flames
it's in
connection for a
animals what animals what animals are
you talking about that looks like
atlanta no because never he bought 50
cent's mansion it wasn't anything else
in connecticut yeah i think that's in
connecticut
look it up that tree didn't have to it
was like mr t he bought a house in
atlanta or something like this amazing
atlanta's great [ __ ] trees have been
there for 300 years cut them all down
which camera's on me
if i was rick ross's mom
i would teach him atlanta georgia
there you
go i'd hold his little body yeah
wow you bought it for a 54 mil
and you don't spend 10 grand on trees
yeah his glasses he bought the house 54
mil there you go right there you go 10
000 square foot in fort lauderdale i'm
14. oh yeah you could afford that but
then he bought a mansion
georgia
yeah it used to be evander holyfield's
house i don't know why in georgia why
had to go
54 that's the house right there so yeah
that's atlanta yeah also 21 bathrooms
his reason to cut down an oak tree was
because it was messing up
he owns a bunch of the wing stops
yeah oh yeah yeah he like did he start
wing stuff or he oh no he got in early
on he owns a ton of wing stuff yeah rick
ross yeah he he actually came up with
lemon pepper
what like lemon pepper like flavor yeah
the the flavor yeah because
they go to magic city uh nightclub the
the club and they like to because they
have really good food there he's like
man we can't be grounding these asses
with sauce all over our hands we need a
dry rub that's where they came up with
the lemon pepper
pepper
pepper chicken it's weird that will be
that would have been 100 million dollar
idea yeah my hands are yeah i can't feel
these tips hot sauce these tits are now
all songs
like these strippers are complaining
we're getting teriyaki sauce all over
them be your goddamn self
we're done
he's doing it i mean lemon pepper
chicken let me put her chicken wow
that that'll probably be how he's
remembered really
boy tussle i like your school that boy
kind of tussled yeah how old are you
jeff i am 39.
oh y'all say me he looks young i'm 38.
are you 38.
you're the youngest well you're the
youngest i'm sure yeah 87. how did you
know that because the wow the terrible
poem was born in 1987.
and you said we're the same age you
can't get over the poem ladies
if i was born
in 1921 on a plantation i would tell
everyone slavery's bad and that there
should no you wouldn't
you would just live the way people live
that's right and now she's going i could
change one of the most evil guys
if i was a hypothetical situation
like you'll see all over the media
everything they'll show these ukrainian
like the fighters and just these
powerful people with guns and they're
fighting imagine if it was america or
shows like the the president of ukraine
like i'm not running we're fighting then
i look at our government officials like
god man we have so many soy boys oh yeah
because what is it like hard times
create hard men and
you know hard times i can't remember
these yeah that's not it but weak man
weak men create hard times hard times
creations strong men strong i want to be
around you all day
i want to be around you as much as i can
all day long the fact that you would
start a saying you don't know
it's like george bush you know trick me
once yeah that's fine
fool me twice and i know they say shame
on you
if you're born into
how does it go you don't know you know
what bothered me though
you know what it is i think
i boiled it down i brought
so when i was watching all the white
people march during uh blm without math
and i couldn't figure out what it was
though but why was it bothering me right
and i figured it out it's like they were
so outraged yeah the george floyd thing
and i god bless right i understand yeah
but i think what bothered me was that
the most outraged they were doing this
but didn't cost them anything yeah so if
you marched in the 60s and you could as
a white person you could lose your
everything it's your job oh no go
protest in russia right now right right
the war goes for you you get dogs turn
on your hoses turn on used to the black
people that were protesting in selma and
those places they were taking high
stakes high stakes right those white
people
and they're doing nothing to actually
they're doing zero to actually make the
world a better place jordan peterson
said it but he's like to have a sign
that says like racism is bad it's like
you're not virtuous
of course racism is bad yeah yeah
you just wasted a sign yeah are you
against slavery homelessness is wrong
it's like duh no [ __ ] you're not good
for saying something i saw a white chick
in the beginning at blm she said she was
watching in beverly hills and said all
police are bastards oh yeah and i was
like do you know what happens in a
society the next day to people like you
and there are no cops i know tons of
cops with dads
she doesn't even know what bastard means
you know what what a dumb [ __ ]
see and that's the point i'm making
that's that devil yeah
that's that handsome devil
a little bit more on the ukraine's stuff
oh no so this brewery
in the history of ukraine i don't know
right you keep going down this route my
career is right now you get excited
though it's pretty cool though so this
brewery is actually making a ton of
molotov cocktails for obviously the
citizens well that's not good
but i mean they're this they're
indiscriminate man
is he making money off this how does it
work no this is for free they're free
because they have the skill set to do
this so they're doing it for how do they
make it no they're making fire
molotov cocktails okay okay that doesn't
work against the tank oh that's what
malta
oh yeah you can't drink them oh there's
only i know i'm sitting here i was like
you're making drinks yeah you're not
going to relapse on those chefs yeah
okay
you could be around though that's the
thing
that gets me though those are the
cocktails you wouldn't mind
yeah
you feel like you're doing something
all right uh so wait so he's making
about all the citizens have gathered and
they're making bombs the brewery the you
know all the mix mix yeah guys what a
mixologist they're putting they're doing
together and they're handing them out
they're doing what they can yeah they're
hanging out
and we're dealing with so
to like
see that
but what did do you see that thing that
brogan posted about the drone
that [ __ ] like the military is coming
up with and they don't know what it is
but it's like
it it's so crazy to look at the future
of weapons did you see that video trying
to find instagram dude can i ask a quick
question why does this it keeps popping
up with how to cook rice
it was probably in his searches for the
last i had i was in camp you don't know
how to keep crap
in a camps on a camp stove we didn't
know how to do it okay we went camping
last weekend this week yeah how was it
it's fine you
were camping you thought to yourself man
we need some rice out here
you always have to have rice
i don't want to be too stereotypical but
it was in yours
yeah it's so funny that pops up there
too though
we didn't catch anything brand new so
joe was talking about some sort of drone
los angeles this is if you see it you go
your guns oh [ __ ] oh for sure yeah my
your technology my guns aren't for i
don't think that it will work against
our government i believe that they'd
probably be on my side i hope i would
hope yeah but if someone breaks into my
house i guess i got nine millimeters
that's what my guns are right yeah
that's right man some kid probably just
want my tv and i'm gonna blow him into a
million pieces yeah that's gonna kill my
neighbor's kid because the bullet goes
through the wall
and i'm just guy i got like i have a
gleal
some kid just wanted me to go like that
tackle shotgun it's like a huge rifle
it's like this huge like uh israeli
thing yeah
all right uh what post b oh dude just
keep going down it's [ __ ] oh it's an
old one do you remember it you don't
remember you'd like to see you like to
scroll down i know it was i remember it
and i was like oh my god it's all it's
old video we're fine yeah okay
like terrifying the idea was like i was
like if that's what we have to worry
about is this [ __ ] yeah that's it
what is this thing
so enjoy that
what does it do that's that'd be a
weapon that's that's that's true look at
the top comment who else is convinced
that's boba fett's [ __ ]
that's pretty i mean that [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] like crazy does it film it no it
theories it's got weapons apparently
it's got a weapons payload i enjoy that
the thing china like when we see like
they everyone thinks it's ufos they
think it's just chinese drones or
russian drones yeah well that's that if
you saw that you go that's a drone i
mean
just the sound was alarming yeah but
have you guys like don't get wrong
like that is something yeah we can hear
that that sounds like a banshee from
[ __ ] van helsing
but my nephew's gonna ask me for one of
these now my son has two of them yeah so
they have these frisbees they go like
that and they have facial recognition so
what you do is you launch it and it goes
and go anywhere and just goes it goes
zoom on your head and detonates what the
[ __ ]
what movie have you been watching that's
that's a real technology that equalizer
three guys stopped seeing scary things
for two minutes
we're all trying to tell you yeah i'm
gonna leave
it's [ __ ] scary you learn about
drones and war all day but have you seen
those drone races on like espn ocho yeah
no those drones are fastest i know they
were doing that
i mean you know nerd alert how do you
fly once it's out of eye shot well
because because they have a camera on
the drone so they're steering it from
the camera i know but then this is like
that thing how do you not run that into
it that's something let me see it that's
government they're like
we're not putting this on the espn yeah
just blowing them out of the [ __ ]
water races how do you cook rice in the
woods
it's an important skill for her oh they
go through obstacles yeah yeah yeah no
it's actually really cool yeah
here this is our championship if we're
that athlete
okay those things seem super gay after
seeing that last one but still you get
the idea
aren't they cool yeah that is pretty
dope i mean that's [ __ ] yeah there's
up to a million dollars now if you win
it seriously yeah they make more than
double fly that over the amazon and
people would pray to it
well they had they now have these drones
the size of mosquitoes that can spy on
you you know i don't believe that right
swear to god bring it up chin effect
cause i'll tell you right now did
anybody believe the one frisbee thing
that attacks your face and blows your
head off your head are gonna show it to
you i would love to see it bring that up
too because it has been known to you
know mind-blowing it's mind-blowing look
at it harvard robotics large fly b that
can fly freely in the lab
it still trails the power cord the
slender carbon fiber it's just half an
inch long they're going to use this to
spy on people it doesn't say that so but
that's the idea that would be the idea
they're coming up with with tiny drones
well a lot of people think birds are
drones yeah yeah i love that birds are
fake have you seen that that's that
guy's no i knew a girl when i first got
delayed i was like you know pigeons are
spies i hear that from my friends all
the time
yeah but i also love the idea that i
would do anything like a general being
interesting to our government our
government would just monitor me all day
and go i think this guy just [ __ ] and
drinks a lot
we gotta stop monitoring the guy i think
it's a ted talk thing where he shows you
how
i don't even see the [ __ ] how you
first shoot how this [ __ ] frisbee
thing it's like a little uh it's like a
little disc like that
and it's like a it's almost like it
looks like a starfish and it [ __ ]
goes to poop and latches on your head
and just
what do you think brian
thinks about him
like his laptop's going what is this guy
using me for all this for
so what did yeah what how how would you
search that's the ted talk right there
i hope that guy doesn't know
this is how
yeah this is frisbee you don't want to
eat frisbee just do it just disc oh no
uh
[Music]
i don't know if it's a ted talk i just
know oh because you said
yeah
hey bubba hey look at me hey baby yeah
he made the sublimation i swear i didn't
i said hey hey
no no that's cool man yeah so it's it's
a it's a starfish hey did your buddy
study about this no no no no i saw it
it goes out in into the room there's a
dummy there's a there's like a you know
that dummy and it recognizes the face it
says oh i know that dummy she's too bad
and then and then blows up
it's [ __ ] now was this on world star
uh no no no
um was the next video of steven seagal
fighting in russia put facial
recognition yeah attaches to face blows
up drone disc you guys have to work way
harder when brian's here
[Laughter]
like
brian's like i can't make it today
they're like oh this would be pretty
easy
yeah they're probably going to talk and
joke now we're going to like this guy's
searching face blow up disc thing i'll
find him
blow up
like he was a ted talk so we type in
drum tech i guess maybe not ted talk
exhausted over that gun
there we go
well that the thing i would see a mile
away and i'd hide my face this is a tiny
thing that actually goes boom and hits
you in the face yeah
and then shoots a bullet in your head
it's so [ __ ] great is this target
person here yeah oh that's just we've
had that for a long time they have
accent in it i'm sure whatever you can
dream of is out there yes
it's just now christian are you headed
uh are you a part of a dodgeball team
why are you dressed like this today
dressed like a high school athletic
trainer
for a show with the chuck taylor's known
as [ __ ] yeah he looks like yeah who's
part of globo gym
he's going to uh yeah i'm sending it you
found it i think i did i'm not 100 sure
does a guy lose his head
um i just say that doesn't say a guy
lose his head wait so who's designing
this uh well i have a lab here it is
here it is oh my goodness much bigger i
can't believe you watch this this has to
be fake
does it attach his head it's so small
your kids probably have one of these
right nope
this is fake not cool i think the camera
angle is fake
[Music]
hell of a pilot
no
that skill is all ai yeah i think the
video is times faster than that is this
from a movie it's from a show or a movie
is an anti-sniper
you just see that
this has to be a movie it looks like a
movie it is shot too
different angles
and there's no crowd they're not even
showing the crowd also you're gonna let
him whiz a [ __ ] weapon over the
audience
and also the dummy doesn't have face
recognition hey you stupid huh he's a
little
goes stupid he goes
in russia check out the city
they're going yeah no he's safe now the
ted talks my mom didn't love me
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you guys no with that i mean it was
awesome there's no way that's really
fake they didn't show the crowd it looks
like a bit of like dummy didn't the the
second time
also the vision the vision from natural
drones this is true
maybe it is yeah let's read some of
those comments maybe yeah yeah people
because they go oh that was a great
scene from consulting you know i don't
know man
i don't know but think about thinking
about the people the people are like
brian that are gonna leave the comments
like thank you for this man it's good to
say that yeah it's like a black mirror
episode or something but it is it is
what they're going to happen also this
is from 2017.
yeah but we have come together you may
seem like it was new i mean i'm not
you guys didn't know about it and i'm
telling you i've never heard about it
because you know that's fake though
right the video is fake didn't show any
of the crowd i don't know buddy i let's
just i don't know wait
shots
why would they shoot it there it's a
little dramatic i can't think of any uh
thing live nation or anybody would book
where they'd let you just show a weapon
yeah
like
micro killer drone is real a lot of risk
involved in that presentation but also
we've never seen that guy has 5 000
subscribers it's a dramatized near
future yeah so it's just oh yeah so
black mirror [ __ ] yeah it's all right a
little stupid huh
no i know yeah we all i like the way
i'll give you credit
and i also think we're going to be able
to time jump no dude that's going to
happen that's probably here now three
years ago yeah
it was five years ago for sure hey
have you seen that documentary uh
butterfly effect
with that guy guys
have you seen the the new documentary
they've made three of them back to the
future
i can't believe we can do that dude they
followed up with hot tub time machine
[ __ ] you guys man i'll get you guys i'll
get you guys
at least it was real at least you did
see a thing right
right
here chin bring up that deloitte that
goes back to the future this thing's
[ __ ] crazy what they're doing these
cars man you know what the giveaway was
was the angles and the uh i mean and not
showing the car i believe they have
those now
you hope it's been enough years it's
been five years dude yeah stupid why
would they make that five years huh
a lot of it's secret you guys don't know
anything i like how he started like hey
have you guys seen that thing you said
it yeah right just to give it credit and
then when we have a computer we go keep
grabbing attention
oh go to a deep web
talk
to your head right now do you think they
have that
uh no i don't know i think that's a dumb
website yeah yeah
that's a different you know why because
bullets are the thing you gotta because
it's also the future
chemical warfare
if you want to take out a big yeah
if you want to if you want to take out
like an assassination like a president
or something yeah but we do that now
that's fine yeah yeah we but we
we
just
those yeah we have those we have regular
trucks yeah biden took out also kids and
and a really bad person with no drones
yes yeah obama did the same thing
there's too many great ways to kill
someone you don't need that little we do
have facial recognition the question is
do they have a gun your head right now
do you think the pentagon has something
that small like no
why not i don't care a little chemical
they could probably
just like there's just better ways i
feel like that's kind of like
earlier we were talking about you we
were saying like the drone things flying
around with the one that sounded scary
yeah like a rocket and then you were
like yeah people probably see those and
think they're like aliens or whatever
yeah but does that mean you don't
believe like in ufos and aliens and
stuff i don't know i really don't have
opinion i do not know nobody does nobody
else does i think human beings probably
i think we probably have technology
right now that seems ufo like i know but
i mean i think ufos are definitely no i
i definitely don't know
i believe in that i don't think we're
alone i don't think we've found one yet
though i think we have and the
government knows but they're not going
to tell us because they want to create
panic right i definitely believe in all
that there's all this weird [ __ ] would
you believe in bigfoot right yeah get
out
why do you think you're coming here get
out though you know why bigfoot are you
a flat earther too no way dude that's
not related
wait wait wait wait wait wait you little
bit though i know it is yeti why do you
think it's not the same
where is he he's everywhere
yeah i think there's hundreds of them
thousands maybe no it's just i think
it's just a big of course it's not just
one there's a big like why can't they
get a better picture of them now because
one our camera quality so think about
this i could give you a million
arguments here's the thing we know
nothing about our caves we know nothing
about our woods and the people no we
don't our cave systems people go missing
all the time in the forest but yeah
carry on yeah and so like these things
could just know how to live in caves and
come out when they need water and food
and like also here's the thing
nobody go so who's in the woods native
americans uh
lagers these people right all these
people that go in the woods native
americans aren't in the water yeah they
live out in the woods
yeah they don't live in the woods you
know yeah i like how you said i got a
million dollars
you don't see the argument of america
that was pretty [ __ ]
i was really hungry
for an argument
i know i'm not doing good let me start
off we have a cave system we know
nothing about yeah let me start over
let me start over
anybody who's in the woods
not natives sorry about that
forget that
i said what edit that out tricking that
from the record
anyone who's in the woods doesn't do
anything once the sun goes they're not
all tromping around at night
right you go you sleep the sun goes down
you go to sleep when you're camping you
yeah so like it's a nocturnal monkey
that lives in the woods and walks around
and does monkey [ __ ] at night are
monkeys nocturnal are there any
nocturnal monkeys i don't believe i
don't think so well bigfoot
is the only knock down it's just a big
bipedal huh
look at this see if there's bipedal
chimpanzees in the [ __ ] um oh there's
your bigfoot yeah yeah oh he's cute oh
tiny little bigfoot can you pull up a
picture of bigfoot no because it's not
real
it's not real dude i'm telling you
that's what i'm saying look up though
you're too matter of fact about it look
up by real bro giant
gigantopithecus google that
giant
no that's real gigantic really
now look look it up gigantic pythagorean
orangutan is a proven thing that if you
go to like the museum they say that
they're that they know that they were
real it was just a big monkey that
walked and it was upright right as a
bipedal hominid and what it would and
they came from asia who's driving when
asia
when asia was connected to america they
believed that they migrated
about only bigfoot that's all i know
i know right you know about a continent
i don't even know there was a war till
today but i know some bigfoot yeah it's
like the only thing i know about oh my
god i'm telling you so they just think
they're insane
yeah they think it's just they're just
still there
because no one's using our technology to
find a bigfoot because they think it's
dumb and not real zero evidence though
right tons of evidence where we have
hair we have videos we have pictures
videos we have tons of sightings yeah
great videos i don't think so there's
great videos
you know what happens every time i try
to talk about bigfoot it goes like this
right it goes terribly yeah and then and
then after like an hour it's just me
going please just tell me you believe in
bigfoot
just lie to me just lie to jeff and say
yes you're just a giant bigfoot
it is hard to find things in the woods
no i'm with you man it's hard yeah
serial killers go there little kids go
missing in the woods they're wearing a
pink jacket going mom dad and they go
missing yeah sure yeah so if now if
there's something that lives out there
knows how to run around not trying to be
found you could hide rogan how many
times have you seen a bear
uh in real life having a wild bear never
seen one person never four times never
it's very hard yeah and we know there's
millions of bears in the woods yeah now
take a [ __ ] monkey that's really rare
that's your best argument a terrible
argument no it isn't sorry out of balls
i know guys who's on star goes we don't
know much about cave yeah and i said of
america
although i will say this in the congo
they were finding crazy [ __ ] rogan every
week would be like buckle up guess what
there are deer that eat fish yeah we
have people we haven't discovered yet
yeah so like i'm just saying i think
that there's people are seeing these
things and they go oh you didn't see
that i mean we we know more about space
than we do our own ocean to be fair so
who knows yeah
but i mean now you could some unlock
this monster i'm into that well that's a
lake though that they've already like
searched with the lasers and stuff
pretty hard yeah that's a large animal
to keep people they they can use uh yeah
i'm like yeah there's still something
shiny at all yeah we don't know about
the ocean if it's in the ocean
anything's possible it's basically
you're saying bigfoot's essentially a
hairy human
oh i don't think it's related to us i
don't think well he walks on two feet
that doesn't mean anything all right
he's a prime minister what about the
world of evolution
the only thing i have is bigfoot
he's the only thing he has
i don't know why he cares about that how
does he get you should never care this
much about anything
i love that you truly believe in me i do
it's basically it's another teacher
scandal yes well i i guess when they
looked into her history she's not really
a teacher but so this woman that worked
at a school i guess she would
trade vape pens for sex as in she would
give the kids boys vape pens in order to
have sex with her also who's [ __ ]
that that's basically a free vape pen
i'm saying they would [ __ ] for anyways
they already had nine kids come up it
was like 14 to 17 years old and then
they think there's more obviously oh no
how old were the kids wait she's not a
teacher
when i read it i said school yeah so
hold on you can just do that human
trafficking
i guess if they're unjust
yeah maybe there's a better age yo
that's
whoa what is that oh that's those are
some thick glasses look at that she was
just she was just super horny
also like well he says not a teacher or
employee for the district was involved
in the school's booster club
and she has a child in the school system
who has transferred can we get a better
photo of her i think that's what we have
the only one we got we can look her up
though
the question is don't don't these people
realize they are going to get caught
aren't don't they realize
don't they realize they're dealing with
14 17 year olds who their biggest brag
is [ __ ] oh they're going to tell
everybody yeah yeah or even like 38 year
old yeah dude where'd you get that great
vape from oh miss chandler sucked me off
yeah exactly oh here she is oh not fun
not fun
there's definitely way hotter ones oh
yeah
when they're really hot like jesus
christ so they she's got accounts for
human trafficking
yeah i don't know how that plays in but
maybe she might start driving them
across state lines yeah and students
young is 14 14 17. she clearly is sick
in the head yeah that's
nine students they think there's
more very strange
and for vape pins she would coax them
with vape pens yeah that's that's candy
nowadays
yep 14 to 17 kids my dad was cadbury
eggs and [ __ ] good and plenties yeah
how good they're doing
vaping and sucking i mean all you have
to do is smoke this yeah
and the last one this just i thought was
interesting i didn't know how much water
boys made in the nfl and apparently to
this former nfl player jake feynman i
don't know if you guys know who that is
nope he said they make around fifty
three thousand dollars a year huh water
boy what is a water boy i got an
interesting thing related to this water
jesus brings out water
simon's a monster guess how much
guess how much a nhl dentist makes
oh a team dentist every team has a
dentist oh they do because i guess so
you say hundred thousand a year five
hundred thousand dollars
no money because they don't get their
teeth fixed huh
maybe no money because they never did
yes that's no they all have a dentist
that needs to travel with them they have
to pay him right and he's also it's like
a very archaic form of dentistry because
when the puck hits it and they need that
right now they've got to preserve all
that 500 500 100 grand what do you think
[ __ ] i don't know man uh you got to do
it right there they had a whole podcast
yeah they have to do it there a million
dollars okay
zero
zero dollars because they they get free
season tickets and they just like being
the team's dentist and they still have
their original practice but like they
have their their normal their side gig
yeah but they just like they get to be
part of the brother team
well i'm with steve i'm with steve byrne
we meet this famous hockey player i
don't know his name six tall guy big guy
and he's got no teeth he's got only this
side of his teeth that's his choice i
know and i'm like and i'm sitting there
and i'm like you didn't have any teeth
and
and i said i could finally you know me
i'm like hey bro i mean what's going on
with your teeth yeah he goes ah [ __ ]
you lose them in hockey and it's kind of
like a badge of honor you kind of really
a lot of guys are like that's the best
one
like meanwhile he's 38.
just from here the this one this one and
this one he got knocked out that's
terrible it's not it's not a great look
when you don't have teeth on one side of
your face pretty savage handsome guy
actually i guess pretty savage he's
probably way more handsome if he had
those teeth more or maybe just looks
like 100
have you ever put like a straw in front
of one of your teeth just to see what
you look like
yeah i go from
whatever i am now to zero oh yeah yeah i
just go i just look at it go jesus these
teeth are pretty important
hockey players that i know it's going to
come as a shock to you when they're in a
suit they look good and they do do well
with all hockey players cat would you
holler
that was hollow that was aggressive that
was aggressive today
holler at who uh hockey player uh like
that looked like that but it was like
okay
i need to see like a close-up photo
yeah
he does so well
because that guy had no if that's that
guy was missing teeth it's all man he's
all men oh he is good looking dude
henrik lundqvist is also you can look
him up henry he's gorgeous for a guy
i know
henrik what is it oh there's henrik
there it is i talk about uh i talk about
bigfoot the way he talks about hot
hockey players
[Laughter]
oh he was the goalie who retired yeah
yeah he was a he's a badass so cat that
dude had no teeth
he does have pete though
yeah it's all this is a tricky question
i don't know i feel like i
i prefer a guy who can make me laugh and
then like looks come later if they're
funny and like cool to hang out with yes
we're talking about love is blind cat
huh you need go on love is blind i'm
good
that's how they do it i don't i'm not
interested in that no i'm like her
i just don't think those love
competitions ever work out for anybody
except for maybe that one couple the
first season it's really it's super
rough yeah i just feel like it's uh
island when watch love island the
[ __ ]
there's only like one every three or
four seasons right who work out
because there's uh tommy and molly may
there was olivia and alex who didn't win
but they're having a child now like most
couples don't work out from there i bet
those shows would work out great if
there's no social media
yeah yeah because what happens is now
you're on the show
people have careers off of it so then
what happens is you start getting all
these other opportunities well you
didn't have that you know you know i
thought i loved alex but now this is
looking pretty good yeah you know you
start
getting because now they're looking you
know in the world's your oyster yeah
they used me to trick the to trick the
cast no yeah because they they so the
first season they didn't know they were
gonna be on it right i don't know what's
the concept of the show too hot to
handle was uh they put a bunch of like
really hot singles in there they all
love to have sex and they're all so
proud of it too i [ __ ] every day and
you're like all right take it easy and
then they reveal
that the uh they reveal that the
like every time you hook up you lost
money right yeah they reveal that um
you're not gonna get to have sex with
each other you can't kiss you can't
touch you can't do anything and you're
all gonna have to live in this house
with each other just jack off uh well
you can't even masturbate you'll lose
money and at the end if you guys all do
good and nobody touches each other
you'll get this big pot of money but
every time you do something you'll lose
well how do they a little bit of the
money enough you go in the bathroom
there's cameras everywhere yeah so when
they did the season two they didn't want
they didn't want people showing up to
season two going all right i'm gonna
make they were prepared for it you know
so they had to trick of these p these
kids into thinking they're on a dating
show and i came out and said hey this is
uh whoever parties the hardest is gonna
win the most money and whoever falls
asleep first is to be eliminated we
basically encourage them to [ __ ]
touch each other and then reveal that
they're actually on season two if
they're too out to handle uh oh wow so
we had to like trick them that's good
but i got to be in turks and caicos for
like a month and a half which was that's
the best part of it is that right wasn't
it that's the reveal too hot to handle
yes yeah these girls were pretty good
but they were all young
yeah did you
dated him no no i was i had a girl did
you hook up with him
no but all you know what's funny is that
all these guys tattoo in the world a lot
of the guys lied about their height so
like they told the producers they were
like all these you know they're because
they're all very attractive right she's
gorgeous yeah she was actually so
aggressive
really yeah there was like a part where
i was like waiting just like off stage
to like
i wasn't supposed to talk to him or talk
at all which i didn't i was just like
standing off like waiting for me to come
down and read my part and she said i
have to go to the bathroom and they let
her go up to the bathroom and then uh
she walked by me she goes
uh she just grabbed my ass
and i was like that's pretty interesting
no no i loved it did you do a video on
instagram saying if you were her dad i
should have said if we if you know if i
was a girl and
you did that she's pretty attractive
yeah boy they are too hot to handle they
get mad hot they are very happy all so
young though this is the one i like the
most
how how old are they she's like a
bartender from toronto how old are they
uh they're mostly like 21 22.
oh don't don't pose like that though
yeah right how's he getting abs when
he's straight up like that
my abs only show when i do this kind of
hunchy thing
that kid was short
uh the first one they showed was the
shortcut
oh maybe that guy maybe that guy's the
short guy yeah yeah
he looks different there he has small
arms it was just so funny because he was
like super hot and he came out and he's
like five one you're like what yeah yeah
that guy's gonna try and get these tall
birds
oh that guy wasn't there he was the
stripper oh they must have added him
later or something when i was gone yeah
i guess i watched that that guy's done
some strange things
yeah
i watched it my girl would watch it and
you got into it huh yeah you just you're
there i'm there so i'm watching this
[ __ ] was he your favorite oh this guy's
special he played football you play for
the seahawks yeah yeah he played pro but
very terrible i was gonna say oh yeah if
he's that young he didn't yeah as much
as i did yeah he didn't play yeah he's
on like special teams yeah when people
say that it can be a lot of things i
mean right interesting i like that they
show all these guys all these beautiful
people like looking great and i think at
the top of this article was just like a
photo of me yeah i was like some
terrible photo oh that must be different
but still i was like that photo sucked
about what your thought
that's fun
you guys saw a timepiece and your job
was just to be there as a host i had to
trick them into thinking they were on a
different show so sometimes they would
film me doing like challenges with these
they were they weren't even actually
filming it we just had to convince them
that they were on a show called party
down or something oh wow nope
jeff died let's not look at this come on
what about no this is when you're doing
it yeah yeah tour dates oh uh that's the
end of it man man yeah i didn't want to
know we know you're we found out you're
a big big bigfoot fan bigfoot fan
big fan of brian callan you're a good
man i'm going to be around you all the
time pay me oh come and work south my my
lives in greenwood march 3rd
you're going to be important
denver yeah see this is how i learned
that i can't go to do the the thing
you're doing the ufc campaign yeah that
have been great i know i've never been
to mccurdy's how does it work the fight
companion we just put on the big
pay-per-view and then we drink whiskey
and talk [ __ ] well i drink whisk
everybody else doesn't i would that's
why i wanted you on the show yeah and
you just talk [ __ ] while watching the
fight yeah it's fun jeff you do a lot of
stuff i've never i've never done hyatt
downtown austin never did comedy work
south you've done something except oh
that's right that's right that's right
yeah i did it together yeah i've never
done mccurdy's comedy club in sarasota i
don't even know what hyatt downtown
austin is it's probably a pro it's a
private event that's why i do a lot of
corporates like this is so weird
you're not a corporate guy they've it's
just gonna sound terrible on camera but
i'll just be honest people go i like
what this guy's doing well let's hire
him for my like thing and then and then
all the cuffs are off then they go hey
talk some [ __ ] for like it's almost like
they've like hired a comedian who's
gonna like i just performed for a bunch
of farmers they i flew to
uh gosh i don't even know what state of
iowa i think mm-hmm
and then the guy that picked me up from
the airport in a truck drove me two
hours
a big barn that had all these semis in
it and it was like a bunch of farmers
did you see bigfoot i wish dude i know
right but like they paid me heaps of
money to just go talk [ __ ] to a bunch of
farmers and then drove me back two hours
what's that and they like it was amazing
yeah but like it was almost like it was
almost like comedy's becoming this like
secret thing like well yeah you get this
comic you come and spit it truth yeah
and you don't like acting you you do not
want to be an actor i've done some
acting but i'm not i don't enjoy it yeah
they make you sit around too much yeah
hurry up and wait when also like i don't
i if we got to do this while i'm waiting
that'd be great but they put you in a
trailer and the second you try to come
out to get like craft service or coffee
or something or talk to another human
they're like no you got to stay in there
like i'll go get whatever you need i was
like i don't want you to get it yeah
yeah i want to go i uh
that's the secret you know that yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah i'm good waiting around a
lot in a [ __ ] match yeah this is way
better than acting yeah comedy's way
better than anything it's way better
acting sucks the only good part of
acting was like i got to go to a movie
theater and like see myself and i was
like oh that's me
and that's like
i'm doing hangover chew and who what's
his name the guy uh [ __ ] paul giamatti
uh he had been nominated for like uh i
don't know golden globe or something and
i was like dude congrats good for he was
playing
hamilton or something i don't know what
was that oh yeah yeah i remember that i
was moving sideways i think was up for
award-winning yeah this was but this is
after and i go i go congrats man he goes
yeah yeah thanks and i go was it alright
he goes it's
you know it's just [ __ ] you know i'm
here with you guys you're all funny and
being silly i get to hang out all day
when you're on a set sometimes like that
everybody's in character and nobody's
talking to each other yeah i know aren't
actors are weird too i'll just say that
i've met like three actors that i
genuinely joined the conference oh we
can't have them on here we used to have
back here and it was a night when
[ __ ] i did a movie it was a rom-com
where i played anna camp's like husband
and me and anna camp hit it off like
very well like she's the coolest chick
in the world and then i realized oh i
just think that because all the other
actors were terrible yeah yeah that's
why i thought we were clicking so much
because everyone was just such
dude when when i won't say his name was
doing lincoln with
daniel day lewis yeah i said what was
that like he goes he goes well daniel
day-lewis wouldn't talk to you unless
you asked him about events as they
occurred he stayed in character
i'm not kidding so he comes in and he's
like sorry about that [ __ ] and daniel
day-lewis has never character but he
drank diet coke that sounds dangerous he
was lincoln and then if you asked him
anything he'd say i don't know what you
mean they said well sorry about that
business in cincinnati yes well we we we
had some problems there
like dude you gotta get it you guys
that's so dangerous well it's also it's
also exhausting but i get it
what is coca-cola you're like no you
know what coca-cola is cool why is that
puerto rican over here you're like jesus
christ
chris christie who had who was an artist
who had cerebral palsy and no can only
use his left foot and painted with his
left foot yeah
well the story goes he was in a
wheelchair the whole time and
people had to take he wanted to it was
like when people would take him take a
[ __ ] and wipe him he wanted to know what
that humiliation was like
okay do you think about being associated
oh my god there's a great old like
anecdote it's i'm gonna botch it because
i don't have a prayer but it's something
something like this where this uh this
actor and he had a scene the next day
with this young kid he was supposed to
be like an orphan the kid was and he was
supposed to be this like drunken
homeless guy or whatever so he spent the
whole night staying awake and just
drinking and so he'd look all junked up
and and and the kid the child actor
comes to set the next day and goes oh
wow you look rough and he goes yeah i
stayed up all night i drank and i really
wanted to be in character the kid goes
you should try acting
that's actually a story about the
marathon man with dustin hoffman yeah
olivia but that's the same thing yeah
just act like you're literally stupid
you should why don't you try acting
differently
he's eating him daddy so
he's been he's
out all night running he's plays the
marathon he's been tortured just like
that and and laurence olivier fun eating
his breakfast yes thank you very much
i'll have a little coffee thanks about
to shoot you he's like why don't you try
acting terrible
bring up bring up really quickly
what do you call that method yeah yeah i
want you to just see what think about
this for three months bring up my left
foot just bring i want you to see what
he did for three months bring this up
now watch this just any clip sure or
whatever you want which i i heard the
cameron diaz brother and uh uh something
about mary
what method too who the
mary the brother with uh
well
this isn't as a kid you want him as a
kid you should move ahead to see this
one yeah probably
this is where the podcast comes the
screeching halt oh yeah
also does brian think this is real
that's by the way that's what he had to
do the whole time oh my gosh
so you enjoy that
my left foot
yeah he did that for
three months dude he's amazing but
actors are weird
i love him
brian didn't you play joe rogan in a
movie
yes i did
warrior so what did you do for that
character um i actually called rogers
they read me they wanted rogan they
never got this they wanted rogan
and uh so i call i i call rogan or i
text him and i go hey do you want to do
this movie and he goes
dude honestly unless it's a boatload of
cash i'm just too busy what a good guy
that he can say that yeah i play him and
i i said do you have any advice he goes
just take yourself completely out of the
equation don't ever mention yourself and
just be the guy so i basically i played
brian callan in warrior so thank you
very much everybody there you go
absolutely i loved that movie that's a
good choice
it's a great movie i haven't seen it
either yeah i'll watch anything with tom
hardy and i've only been disappointed
once and he's made hundreds one movie
uh and it's not that it was a bad movie
no i like venom venom too though i saw
venom too i liked that i didn't well
actually i wasn't crazy about the uh
i didn't like the girl bad guy and woody
harrison was terrible and even though
he's great no but he's terrible in it i
thought he was i thought the voice that
he did and everything was pretty i like
how they made like venom funny and all
that that is terrible because he's
supposed to be a bad guy but uh i think
you don't like superhero stuff i don't
think it does all right it makes sense
so uh but what does this the movie that
i didn't like that tom hardy was in it
wasn't because he wasn't a great actor
it's just it was over my head he played
like a twin brother oh no
was it the western
not that it wasn't great i just i didn't
he was [ __ ] awesome he's so good dude
yeah he's so i was just in a group of
people the other day that didn't like
him as bane and i was like what oh he's
great he was great as bane
that voice is so cool and like he's all
jack jack
okay brian you ever see him in bronson
yeah i love him
oh actually bronson there's a story i
tell all the time one of my friends is
really hung up on her ex boyfriend and
she won't stop talking about it and shut
up about it and i actually quoted a
bronson story tom hardy when he was um
preparing for the role of bronson do you
guys know who bronson is like the
craziest inmate in the world yeah yeah
yeah and he's also like a masochist like
he he he'll sometimes
intentionally provoke the guards so
they'll come in and beat him with like
he loves it yeah he's a blood thirsty
guy so anyways british guy um
tom hardy keeps trying to call or the
guy keeps trying to call tom hardy to
get a hold of him yeah because he wants
to prepare for this role and tom hardy's
like really just hasn't picked up the
phone all the times that this inmate is
allowed to call heart he's like i got
him finally calls him and he tom hardy
goes hey i'm really sorry about
everything you know like i've just been
i'm going through this terrible breakup
and i just haven't been available and
i'm super sorry let's let's talk about
your life and he goes oh you're going
through a breakup huh he goes yeah and
i'm just i can't get over it i love her
you know and he goes
you remember the floods tom and he goes
the floods remember when we had those
floods and he's like yeah he goes
remember there was that story about that
kid that got his foot stuck in the grate
and the floods were climbing and the kid
drowned and tom's like jesus yeah
he goes that wouldn't happen to me tom
and he goes okay why why he goes cause i
had to cut it the [ __ ] off
i would have telled him cut my [ __ ]
foot off
and and tom's like like he's confused
and he goes same thing with your little
breakup
cut it off if you want to live
and it's like jesus like that
that's like just such a man way to think
of it like you're sitting around sulking
and not answering your phone oh the girl
doesn't like me cut it the [ __ ] off
to live
yeah yep
it's a hardcore analogy but yeah
i hope you find bigfoot man i know i'm
sorry that happened no i'm proud of you
i feel like i put a wedge between me and
brendan's friendship now
and you're a bigfoot guy you know your
flat earth had been nice no that's no
thank you no thank you that's absolutely
i'm a flat marsher though for sure oh
this [ __ ] god
earth is round bro
yeah
i'm a flat martial
let's see where are we yeah march 9th
the shop and friends again probably
everyone in this room will be there yep
that's at the hollywood improv once
you're only 8 p.m let's sell that [ __ ]
out it'd be the sixth consecutive
sellout the hollywood improv and then
nashville is next week thursday friday
saturday zany's nashville tennessee
and then chicago is march 24th
through the 26th chicago illinois march
24th 26th but uh zany's nashville you're
up next week thursday and friday
saturday
ryan oh my god oh we got a fight
campaign saturday uh josh barnett matt
matron myself that's a good 7 p.m ufc
272 only available on thick boy network
i got apples in wisconsin this weekend
skyline comedy club uh thursday friday
saturday march 3rd 4th 5th jason ellis
coming in helping me out phoenix arizona
stand up live march 11th to the 13th by
the way that's my dad's going to come oh
good that's a friday through sunday show
i i'm done sunday i'm never doing it
yeah it's in phoenix everyone's dad's
gonna come urban
very old
louisville kentucky louisville comedy
club me and jason ellis again march 17th
through the 19th miami florida at the
end of the month he's on the road
everywhere and then port charlotte march
25 27 then port charlotte you're going
to be portrayed right now
this weekend saturday yeah this is
friday saturday and uh thursday i think
yeah and i got some other [ __ ] in april
and then um march 10th through the 12th
i'll be in springfield missouri at the
blue room comedy club and then april 8th
through april 9th i'll be in salt lake
city at wise guys comedy club oh i love
wise guys yeah i'm still love it
jeff we love you man yeah guys wait did
you say your dates like we got them yeah
okay okay there's no judgment with your
bigfoot stuff yeah yeah it's really just
going to it's going to ruin your week
because i'm going to send you
legit evidence please and you're going
to go oh god
i'm sorry honey jeff's blowing my phone
up with all this bigfoot crap now i'm
just ready to get drunk and spew bigfoot
[ __ ] i could talk about it all day all
right we love you man we're out